Five Guys who've been killed at four
Benjamin actually which was up the Elm
Valley and five guys have been hitting
one one go
and I remember the the stretchers coming
over the ramp and um
so I'm gonna get emotional um they were
all covered in Flags so there was a
rifles flying on one of the bodies
um a Union Jack on one
um a Welsh for like on one of them and
each body had a different flag on it and
there's nothing you can say to those
guys that's going to make that better
what can you compare being in combat to
how does it feel there's nothing yeah
you can't compare it to anything the
adrenaline
um
the way you feel you you I don't know
you laugh sometimes when you hit your
nervous laugh because you're really yeah
over the years
um from when I first got to Afghanistan
you know we'd go into some Landing sites
that have been either mortared or
rocketed the day before or like some of
the fogs that have been in contact that
morning and then we were allowed to go
in
um and then as Herrick got more kinetic
we would then for some of the merch
shots for some of the guys who had who
were T1 so that's the worst kind of
injury we had to get them out because
they had an hour to live we would then
have to go in while the landing site was
still in con under contact but it became
normal your normality bar for fear if
that makes sense kind of started to
climb over the years and certainly for
guys who've done multiple tours by the
time you know you're sat and there's
bullets within past you it kind of feels
normal an albino Yugoslav it's like
these people you know Afghan and Iraq
nine times out of ten we didn't know
where our enemies were because they
weren't in uniform
and you had and the rules engagement
which they told us about to do we had to
wait for them before on us before we
fired on them hasn't changed which was
completely ridiculous
because you could have a farmer digging
his trenches and he'd have a machine gun
in his
and he's just opened fire first
so it's a different type of warfare
Behind Enemy Lines especially that
that's really interesting hearing John
say that because I say he creates
nodding until we all get this to the
Taliban switched onto that they were
really clever and we used to learn at
some sites and they'd have an RPG and
point at us and as long as if they put
it down and walked away we can jit them
even though we knew they had left on
Town towards us unless they're
physically aimed at the aircraft we
couldn't do anything about it which
meant that they could go and collect it
pick it up again and fire it these guys
but because the rules we get are so
strict and it was self-defense you know
you could only ever pull the trigger if
you had honest belief that you were
going to get shot out and it put you in
a very Catch-22 scenario is there
one kind of memory which you would say
stuck with you
if you can identify one What would
what would that be do you think
what memory sticks in your mind well
remember six in my mind
yeah well I think the memory which
sticks in my mind is
the comrade ship
we shouldn't get in civilian life
and we miss it terribly when we come out
of the army
comradeship I think is the most
important memory you can have
yeah I know the comrades who you've
missed out on being killed
they are second yeah banter you can't
beat
Army Band tour movie or whatever
especially in Special Forces I think
there's probably more comradeship than
anywhere else
yeah because you're working a club your
help you're there to help each other
you would never leave a comrade behind
if you could help it's one of the
saddest memories that stick with me
um
is there repatriation
where they were their coffin was carried
back on to the back of a Hercules
and we were all standing standing there
to attention uh without berries on
saluting coffin going you know going
back to the UK on the back of the hook
um
I think that's one of the strongest
memories I have
um only because it just
uh yeah it took my breath away I
couldn't I can't actually
described it it was just um
yeah I didn't it was just but you talk
about a memory that's six of you
sometimes it's not always the good
memories it's not always the good
memories that stick with you
um
I'm sure these guys will agree with me
there's a lot of good memories
there's also a lot of hard memories
I mean my my memory that I always look
back on Herrick was my we had to go pick
up Five Guys who've been killed at four
Benjamin actually which was up the
Hillman Valley and five guys have been
hitting one one go
and I remember the the stretchers coming
over the ramp and um
so I'm gonna get emotional and they were
all covered in Flags so there was um a
rifles flag on one of the bodies
um a Union Jack on one
um a Welch flag on one of them and each
body had a different flag on it and then
they were the guys set the the stretches
down and untouched the bodies and went
back off into the fight and there's
nothing you can say to this guys that's
gonna make that better
I'm not brothership like that
Brotherhood it was so apparent and their
faces as they set their mats dying on
the floor and said goodbye for the last
time and you know that's something that
that Brotherhood is just in your blood
forever so yeah
sorry
do you think you can form the same bunt
in any other way no
no civilians do not understand the way
military work in their headspace
and I always say PTSD oh yeah we all got
PTSD but it's like a train track
you know they're civilian Peterson
there's military and it's level because
we've got PTSD but it'll never crossed
because people never understand this and
we will never understand that you know
but it would go parallel with each other
John what about you what about the
people you served with
people
people that you served with memories
well unfortunately I
memory's aren't all that good I have a
couple of major strokes and I lost a lot
of my memory
but
people I serve with
I suppose there'll always be in my
memory because they were very important
they were my comrades is anyone still
around from the people you served with
people around
I think
there's only two left in my regiment
anyway I'm one of them
[Music]